well tonight local doctors from the
clark county medical society
are gathering virtually to discuss the
rollout of the vaccine
medical professionals from a wide range
of specialties are going to be taking
part in that town hall
8 news now reporter kate houston spoke
to a local ob gyn who is taking part
about the impact the vaccine could have
on pregnant women
this week the american college of
obstetricians and gynecologists
recommended that the coven 19 vaccine
not be withheld from pregnant women
physicians say it comes down to what a
woman thinks is best
for her and her growing family local ob
gyn dr stacy mchale has no concerns
about the covid19 vaccine
she says while pregnant women are not
necessarily at a higher risk of
contracting the virus
they are at a higher risk of severe
complications if they do get it
pregnant women who are high risk for
contracting coven 19 should strongly
consider getting the vaccination while
pregnant
as with most other vaccinations dr
mchale says the recommendation is
different for women trying to conceive
women who are trying to get pregnant
have been advised to not receive the
vaccine in the two months before
pregnancy if at all possible
the american college of obstetricians
and gynecologists notes that pregnant
women were not included in the covet 19
vaccine trials while safety data is not
currently available
the acog adds that there is also no data
to indicate the vaccine should be
withheld
this is a new disease we don't have all
the information
you have to make the best choice with
your health care provider to determine
what the right course of acts are you
kate houston 8 news now